las elecciones estadounidenses ya están
haciendo historia al menos en lo que
tiene que ver con participación
electoral a menos de una semana de los
comicios casi 75 millones de personas
han votado anticipadamente esto
representa más del 50 por ciento de la
participación total en las elecciones de
2016 los expertos proyectan que este
entusiasmo podría llevar a romper la
marca de los 139 millones de votos
registrados hace 4 años
es la primera vez que votamos y estamos
muy emocionados estamos tratando de
hacer una diferencia en nuestro país y
esperamos que así sea
esto podría favorecer a los demócratas
que han alentado más enérgicamente a
votar por correo precisamente el
candidato demócrata joe biden emitió su
voto en delaware desde donde se refirió
a los enfrentamientos en filadelfia tras
la muerte de un afroamericano en medio
de un tiroteo
[Música]
no hay excusa para el saqueo y la
violencia creo que proteger el legítimo
pero para el saqueo no hay excusa y hay
ciertas cosas que tendremos que hacer
mientras avancemos como lidiar con cómo
disminuir los tiroteos letales como el
que vimos
por su parte el presidente de trump
llegó a arizona donde las encuestas
proyectan un empate técnico allí criticó
a biden y se mostró confiado de su
rendimiento en la votación anticipada
con el somnoliento yo no habría
graduaciones fiestas o acción de
gracias' están diciendo que no habría
acción de gracias'
incluso en california la máscara sería
obligatoria y tendrías incluso que comer
con ellas
en la recta final de la contienda
electoral
trump o planea visitar 10 estados en
medio de las críticas por los masivos
mítines durante la pandemia mientras byd
en lo aventaja en las encuestas a nivel
nacional